يأتي الضوء الأزرق الذي يأتي من هاتفك الخلوي
أيضًا بسعر ، أي
تعرض لأي ضوء أزرق ثبت أنه
يثبط إفراز الدماغ
للميلاتونين ، وبسبب ذلك فإنه يقضي
على دورة نوم الجسم ، لذا ينصح الأطباء
بالابتعاد عن الهاتف قبل التوجه.  وضع
أي شيء يمكننا القيام به لمحاولة تقليل
هذا الضوء الأزرق الضار عالي الطاقة ، والسماح
بإطلاق الميلاتونين الطبيعي ،
سيؤدي إلى تحسين أداء
الأفراد ،
تظهر الأبحاث أن التعرض للضوء الأزرق
قد يؤدي إلى زيادة خطر
الإصابة بالسرطان والسكري والقلب.
يمكن أن يتسبب المرض والكثير من التعرض في إلحاق الضرر
بعيونك بمرور الوقت ، وقد بدأ هذا
الجيل والعصر من الاستخدام العالي للأجهزة الرقمية في
الازدهار فقط ونحن
قلقون من حدوث
عواقب على الطريق ، لذا
يوصي الخبراء في الوقت الحالي باستخدام الأدوات
والتكنولوجيا مثل النظارات التي تحجب الضوء الأزرق
لحماية عينيك ، حاول أيضًا
موازنة وقتك أمام الشاشات ،
يمكنك أيضًا ضبط الشاشات على مقربة
وضع t الذي ينبعث منه ضوء أكثر دفئًا يكون أسهل
على عينيك وأكثر فائدة
لدورة نومك للدقيقة الصحية اليوم
أنا Mandy Gaither